linda radelet tu étais non seulement ma
cousine préféré mais elle demeura
pendant des années mon être humain
préféré aura toujours même si je suis
ennuyeuse
fini je te ravir est à jamais de ce
terrible endroit
mais fillon tout ce dont on a tant
besoin et c'est pourquoi voudrait-elle
cent vallées je veux être libre je veux
m'amuser et porter des talons hauts et à
la folie est-ce qu'il n'y a que l'amour
dans la vie oui
celui qui a inventé l'amour devrait être
abattu
[Musique]
nos débuts tam dans le monde
linda est un fruit mûr pour être
cueillies
et l'arbre venait d'être secoué
[Musique]
désire pas ardemment avoir une vie aussi
excitant
je préfère observer les choses
excitantes
singer qu est-ce qu n'ayez pas peur mon
cher matthew motti est presque
totalement domestiqué tout comme do
we see
linda est d'une nature si romantique ce
qui est toujours fatale chez une femme
et moi comment je suis tu es toi fanny
tu t'en sortiras
tu ne peux pas te marier en se basant
sur la romance et l'exaltation si tu ne
te fixe la limite tu n'en aura jamais
assez je ne tiens pas à en avoir assez
espérant que les femmes pourront choisir
qui elles seront indépendamment de qui
elle épouse
avez vous parfois l'impression qu'une
partie de vous avec des forêts dans une
valise est en train de suffoquer pardon
[Musique]
ça vous posera des problèmes
manière inéluctable super du centre
pas ici que je me sens chez moi
sur près de toi
quoi qu'il arrive je serai toujours de
ton côté
[Musique]